[Música]
me passa um lápis cor de pele
muitos de vocês devem ter feito essa
pergunta
dentro das salas de aula por onde vocês
estudaram muitos de vocês devem ter
atendido a essa pergunta eu cresci em
escolas onde essa pergunta era dirigida
para mim e eu respondia a essa pergunta
entregando esse max cor de rosa
essa pergunta me incomodava de algum
modo
mas ali criança eu não sabia o porquê
desse incômodo eu fui crescendo
o tempo foi passando dentro da escola
um dia no meu quarto ano
eu cheguei na sala de aula ea minha
professora na melhor das intenções
fez todos os meus colegas ficarem de pé
e cantarem parabéns a você eu
ingenuamente olhei pra ele disse mas
professora no meu aniversário e ela
respondeu eu sei mas hoje 13 de maio dia
da abolição da escravatura de novo com a
minha ingenuidade
eu respondi com os elementos que a minha
infância permitirá reunir mas eu nunca
fui escravo
essas experiências contrastavam
absurdamente com a família onde eu nasci
e com o modo como eu fui criada
filho de uma mãe professora de um pai
policial civil e advogado na minha casa
o convite pra ler criar produzir
imaginar e sonhar a pessoa que eu queria
ser nunca foi impeditivo
pelo contrário meus pais me diziam que
eu podia ser quem eu quisesse ser desde
que eu estudasse bastante pra ele
mas na escola eu precisava me reconhecer
como a pepa porque aquela era a minha
cor
afinal aquela era a cor do lápis cor de
pele
eu fui crescendo e eu precisei estudar
ingressar na universidade no curso de
letras com 15 anos
aos 19 anos eu tava dentro das salas de
aula das escolas públicas como
professora ea pergunta aquela maldita
pergunta voltava na boca das crianças na
minha frente
nem presto lapso de pé me passa o lápis
cor de pele
eu continuava sem saber responder essa
pergunta eu precisei fazer mestrado
doutorado e me tornar professora
universitária entrar na ufrgs e começar
a entender que essa pergunta ela não
tinha uma resposta mas ela podia ser
respondida uma outra pergunta cor de
pele de quem mais ou menos ao redor do
ano 2000 recebi um convite que faria
qualquer professor universitário jovem
como eu era na época se sente zhu tente
eu fui convidada pela prefeitura
municipal de porto alegre para
participar da semana da consciência
negra e dá uma formação sobre as
questões raciais para os professores da
rede municipal de ensino
eu fiquei enojada mas eu agradeci o
convite e disse eu me sinto muito
honrada mas eu não trabalho com as
questões raciais não pesquisa essas
questões não publicou nada sobre isso e
desliguei o telefone
esse foi um momento de fronteira na
minha carreira estava na minha sala uma
colega diária que se virou para mim e
disse olha para o lado
5º enxerga saque mulher negra como tu tu
tens muito a dizer sobre isso
naquela fala daquela colega eu entendi
que
muito a dizer não era apenas de
teorização mas era do lugar da fala
um lugar que ocupava como mulher mulher
negra dentro de uma universidade pública
era um lugar que precisava se construir
barcos institucionais cotidianos
ele também precisava ser re significar
na minha ação concreta de professora
dentro da sala de aula
chegou o ano de 2013 e surgiu o
possibilidade de criar um curso para
conversar com os professores da escola
pública sobre as relações étnico raciais
ali nasceu união nasceu de uma parceria
bem importante construída com uma colega
chamada danada furtado e uma série de
professores da universidade que toparam
a aventura de discutir aquele
desconforto da minha infância
aquela tristeza que ele mal estar que
ali professora universitária já bastante
madura na carreira eu era capaz de
nomear o meu desconforto tinha o nome
minha tristeza tinha o nome racismo esse
é o nome do meu desconforto
nós sabíamos que nesse curso nós temos
que discutir com os professores as
questões concretas de sala de aula
mais do que as teorizações raciais mais
do que se apropriar da cultura negra
africana e afro-brasileira mais do que
se sentir em coragem de fazer esse
trabalho nós precisávamos urgentemente
ensinar os professores como mediar os
conflitos raciais dentro da sala de aula
nessa primeira edição do curso eu
novamente voltei a sentir o sabor do
racismo
narrado nas experiências que as
professoras que fizeram o curso traziam
do racismo cotidianos útil às vezes às
vezes pesado e perverso machucando
crianças levando ao fogo ao desejo de
abandonar a escola fazendo professores
repente
ari se tinha o mesmo escolhido a
carreira qual é ali
nesse curso em 2013 nove professoras se
desligaram do curso causa não era que o
curso era ruim o que elas não estavam
gostando era bem pior
elas assistiram ao vídeo de abertura do
curso e me enxergaram coordenadora
mulher negra e elas afirmaram não
aceitamos ser coordenadas por uma mulher
negra
isso novamente trouxe o sabor do racismo
a minha boca mas diferente da infância
quando não tinha ferramentas ali ali na
universidade pública acertada de colegas
que tinham um desejo de fazer alguma
coisa eu me senti um poderá dá pra
pensar agora mais do que nunca eu quero
ampliar o neafa eu quero levar esse
curso para mais lugares
eu quero ajudar os professores a
ajudarem as crianças a falar sobre essa
dor a nomear essa dor a pensar sobre ela
e transformá lo porque não precisa ser
assim novamente eu pensei o que pode
fazer as crianças pequenas
tão pequenas que não sabem nomear essa
dor esse sofrimento não sabem que isso
se chama racismo poder discutir as
questões da pertença racial o que pode
fazer as crianças negras terem vontade
de se assumirem como negras terem
vontade de dizer essa é a minha cor ea
minha cor é linda
era preciso criar um material não
existia disponível no mercado brasileiro
nenhum estojo que propusesse as crianças
disponibilizasse tons de pele
nós saímos batendo de porta em porta
tornaria o ouvimos não o pior do que
isso de muitas empresas sequer resposta
sequer aquele email dizendo olha suas
malucas não temos interesse comercial
nisso uma colega escutando a minha
tristeza com este não
o interesse disse conheço alguém que
pode te ajudar
nós fomos bater na porta de uma empresa
local
e aí nasceu nesse setor foi virando
história
esse nascimento eu lembro de um momento
que para mim foi bastante marcante
o dia que nós vamos ver as cores os
bonecos para escolher quais cores em um
compor esse setor
nós estávamos numa cafeteria era uma
manhã mais ou menos fria e nós estávamos
empolgados está no ar e eu como crianças
que acabam de ganhar um presente de
natal
escolhendo as cores e aí o fabricante
nos diz alma
você tem que testar no papel porque uma
coisa é a cor no estojo outra coisa é
como pigmento reagir e nós saímos
pintando e tinha uma garçonete num
cantinho nos olhando e nos olhando que
nem criança quando quer fazer uma
pergunta está constrangida ela nos olhou
no canto do olho disse que escolheu as
cores a compor um estorvo e essa menina
adulta negra encheu os olhos de água
botou a mão na mesa e disse é a minha
cor
esse gesto esse pequeno pequeníssimo
gesto de uma adulta e mostrou que se
estojinho singelo tem uma potência
ele é pequeno pequeníssimo são só 12
cores mas ele traz uma materialidade a
partir da qual a gente pode pensar e
falar a cor da minha pele diz da minha
raça a cor da minha pele é definidora de
quem eu sou
a cor da minha pele diz até onde podem
ir os meus sonhos dos meus projetos de
vida
porque sim
ela pode esse material foi ganhando as
salas de aula foi conquistando as
crianças elas foram encontrando a cor da
sua pele foram pintando seus
autorretratos e foram desejando como a
vitória ter outra cor porque como diz a
vitória eu queria ter a cor o gosto eo
cheiro do chocolate
eu fiz esse estojo pensando também nos
meus filhos eu sou mãe de três filhos
cada um de uma cor
eu pensei muito que eu gostaria de
deixar para o antonio para beatriz e
bibiana a possibilidade de se
reconhecerem na sua pertença racial de
colorirem os seus próprios desenhos de
se orgulharem da cor da pessoa da raça
que eles têm mas não é só para os meus
filhos
esse estojinho que foi ganhando o mundo
que foi ganhando lugares
foi também ajudando a demarcar que neste
país existe uma fronteira uma abissal
fronteira entre ser branco e ser negro
estar de um lado de outro da fronteira
pode significar uma vida plena ou
repleta de dificuldades não precisa ser
assim eu acredito que é possível viver a
pertença negra com orgulho com alegria é
possível discutir com as crianças sobre
o que significa isso é possível ajudar
as crianças brancas a compreenderem que
sim ser negro pode ser maravilhoso
esses são os meus filhos são a minha
vida e colorido
meus filhos me ensinam cotidianamente
nesse desafio que as cores as cores
deste país
essas deste país não tá bem nessa
pequenina caixinha de 12 cores elas
transcendem elas transborda
elas são muito maiores do que um estouro
do pequenino estojo que começou como
invenção de duas professoras incomodados
com as cenas cotidianas de racismo e
conflito racial
ele é pequeno filho e potente porque as
coisas pequenas
guardam uma potência uma semente e se
isto já foi pelo mundo chegou no japão
em portugal na alemanha esse estojo cada
vez que chega nas mãos de uma criança
bem no interior do rio grande do sul
comove toca emociona faz pensar essa
potência
pra mim é a semente da educação
antirracista pensar que sim
nós temos todas as cores todas elas
necessárias todas elas transcendentes
todas elas únicas merecedores de viverem
em qualquer lado da fronteira
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]